[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everybody how is it going oh my music
cut out there okay we'll get that back
on just like that
what's up everyone I'm Persia here and
today I'm show you really awesome
because not only do we get to play
Animal Crossing but today's stream is
powered by troops so we're gonna be
giving away its Belle's gold nuggets
nook miles tickets and actually some
hair realm urge to also from truth and
what's even cooler because I love this
game so much is that I have took some of
the IRL merch and I turned it into
in-game animal crossing merch
so you guys will get to actually
download these designs if you want to
wear them because we're gonna have fun
today but today is not the only day
we're gonna have all this fun because
we're gonna do this again next week I'm
gonna put the coat up for those signs
for you soon so that you can download
them for next time but we'll cross that
bridge when it gets here I have the
players for our field day coming to the
island we were all on the island before
we started but internet things happen
and I've been trashed and now everyone
is back and they're still piling in so
this gives me time to talk to you guys
say what's up what's good Brendan how's
it going I know it's been a minute
it felt good to be back hopefully all of
our players are able to get away safely
we'll see it's in process but yeah the
theme for today you guys is stress
relief and things we can do to kind of
combat stress too it helps stay not only
help you but kind of same in these crazy
times you know so a lot of these games
are gonna be a little wacky fun but
there are themed around things that I
find really relaxing and things that I
like to do to help combat my stress so
hopefully you guys can try it out and
maybe it will help you or you can find
something similar that's more suited to
your needs either way we're gonna have
fun and hopefully find good ways to
combat stress by the end of this and
also make sure everyone gets all the
bills and all the folds and all of
everything so I'm excited I'm wait for
everybody to get into the island I've
worked so hard on this I love you guys
and it was so fun and I was like trying
to craft cool mazes and races and stuff
like that and like cool things we can do
and if you played the rover event some
other races are kind of up my alley
maybe more so just the first one that
we're gonna do but you guys will see
everybody looks so cute also I have my
keyboard hooked up to the switch right
now so that I can type away to our
contestants but I've sent a bunch of
cool stuff so unless everybody's in here
which I think that they are I have to
make everyone my best friend because
some of these games
these games Network and listen because
we need to dig stuff up we have a
scavenger hunt on its way it's really
cool
so hopefully once everyone gets in I put
a trash can by the door so they can
empty their pockets
[Music]
um seems like someone's still trying to
connect but I think we're getting close
to everybody I'm gonna try to send this
best friend requestable quick oh no I
don't want to quit investment I asked to
be best presents alright so the guys
don't know or if you're a newsie Animal
Crossing when you go to someone else's
Island and you're best friends with in
you're allowed to like dig and use your
axe and your shovel and stuff like that
so we are waiting on one more
[Applause]
okay so I also put all the rules and
everything on bulletins on the bulletin
board which was super fun too this game
allows you so much creative freedom so
I'm excited hopefully all these games
work out really really well because I
spent
hopefully they're not too complicated
that's a little bit what I'm worried
about them just being a tad too
complicated but I believe in our
contestants they're gonna believe at
least I mean one race alone the final
race ends in a massive Bell tree-filled
has over a million bells so people not
gonna win with some bells of some gold
today some invoke models tickets also
even some real are hey you got someone
all out for you and this is only one up
to next week we're doing it again but
next week it's gonna be different don't
think you're gonna show up and it's
gonna be the same old games today
no it's gonna be totally different but
we will cross that bridge when we get
there
yay all right everyone's here
I'm gonna give them time to read the
bulletin and empty their pockets let me
let me tell them all they have to empty
their pockets I feel like I try not to
put so many prizes in here that you know
your pockets would be full by the end of
it but it'll be close
yeah okay right you know get shoes items
from Able's before
and breathing eyelines in the friend i
put up a bunch of DIY in the front i'm
looking down on my keyboard because i
scratched off all of the keys on this
keyboard and yeah okay boom okay so i
put the words out there to our
contestants they're gonna run around and
do everything well i show you guys what
we are up to
alright so first of all our little lobby
here hopefully our players will come
back once i've done i put a bunch of
recipes out here you know this there's
so many recipes after building and
building and building
um so for one of our races the very
first one it's called the rise and shine
race and it's basically us getting up
and out of bed every day because
honestly people might not you know
understand this or notice this but
sometimes getting that is the hardest
part sometimes you know you don't even
want to do that and you might end up
staying in bed and then it's just a
vicious cycle but getting out of bed
rising and shining it that's the first
step to having a better dance so that's
why I built this first race around that
concept it's really fun but it also
requires us to get just right we're in
quarantine it's so easy to like stay in
your sweatpants and your PJs all day but
sometimes when I need to pick me up I
actually get dressed and you know do my
hair make myself feel better get myself
ready try to get that look good feel
good mindset going so this is a part of
you know being hired by shoes we're
gonna incorporate the truth merch so
during the race
wake up you go over to
you know get ready and everything's
really cute too
I'm wearing the dress it's my personal
favorite but I've got some goodies some
t-shirts and tanks and then the relaxed
tea on the left is actually a real
design that sure is putting out and
winners of challenges today are going to
get a real-life version of the relaxed
tea so exciting and it's really cute I
love it
I'm a little bit jealous but yes and if
you guys at home actually want to
download these designs here's the
creator code right here at the bottom
left six three five three five four
three eight nine seven zero five because
like I mentioned earlier you know today
is our first streamlet truth and we're
having another one next week a whole new
list of games that were gonna be playing
and one of those games for next time is
gonna be a fashion show so that means
you guys can uh you got a whole week
today overly so you have time so
download one of these designs get an
amazing outfit ready and we also have
some other themes for some other outfits
for the fashion show but this is
definitely a must please grab these
designs download them and get ready for
next week there's only gonna be five
slots though for next week as well we
already filled up all of our slots for
this week with these contestants next
week five more are gonna be on the board
so get ready you guys you have some some
morning here now you have some morning
so it looks like everyone is getting in
their designs ready to go and yeah so
our contestants today we got cheese and
we got Meyer and we've got turn Mitch
and Mary soul I'm keeping score I have a
shop where they just can't see it bum
keeping score
I'm making sure
that everyone gets all work is that
everyone's having fun
yes definitely Brannen I will let you
know your first long list you already
requested it okay so yeah everyone is
learning recipes I love it eat it out
what sounds okay so it looks like
everyone is done I want to show you guys
the bulletin boards so you have an idea
what's going on today first one of
course welcome it's a game spot island
we are powered by truth and this board
has all the rules and info so if you're
tuning in you're interested about coming
next week this is gonna be the process
the rules and regulations they're all
gonna be up here on the bulletin board
you know they typed so much into these
so I tried my best to explain everything
but I'm gonna make sure I explained in
further detail to everyone playing as
best I can
we're limited without what trick in
sight but it's fun but yeah
so rules obviously I mentioned this
earlier and I just went over the whole
spiel about our in-game rich but if you
win a challenge you will get an in real
life piece of merch modeled after the
relax one now we have in the game well
actually vice versa and in every race
and every game I have some hidden prizes
some not so hidden prizes gold medal
gold nuggets just like laying around
everywhere and money and all kinds of
stuff but also some pizza seeds some a
little give and take a little good well
bad but that's my phrase the best thing
about it is putting it in a good
perspective and remembering with good
things
hahaha alright and of course Finders
Keepers whatever you guys dig up out of
the ground whatever you find laying
around it's yours but - with that said
don't be wet head play fair
if someone shakes down the tree and
money falls down don't roll up right
behind them and take their money it's
not right it's messed up be nice and
then of course
you told everyone that download one of
the truth items so that we can have it
be in the race
so the first race right here game number
one rise and try and go through your
routine turn on the sink dig up some
trees and then go and finish the race I
have a little designated area for the
finish of the race game number two
greedy wieners you guys all know about
this achievement I'm gonna have them
kind of race and see who can pluck the
most weeds out of the garden that I set
up I'm gonna show you guys the map after
this too because the map looks pretty
cool and then we have the small
scavenger hunt so that is literally just
a bunch of stuff buried everyone's gonna
have to run around and look for items to
assemble their spa outfit which is
basically just like a bathrobe and some
slippers and like a face mask or the
little cucumber patches cucumber badges
are actually my favorite and then you
and then they got to race to the beach
and lay down in the beach chair and
relax no I also have mentioned mention
that I did a lot of these things to
explain stress relieve things for myself
so the gardening one
I mean it's gardening even in game
gardening can be very therapeutic and
very peaceful so something I recommend
to anybody who likes nature alright you
know maybe you just want to play some
in-game nature things and Animal
Crossing great and then of course this
boat what's what's not relaxing about a
spa sometimes you don't even need to go
somewhere fancy just pamper yourself at
home take a nice hot bat order yourself
some fancy little like bath bombs or
something
treat yourself get yourself a new face
watcher and you know a nice shampoo or
something like that just treat yourself
take care of yourself and that's kind of
why I chose like a spa themed thing
because I think that's something very
important you know for everybody it
doesn't even matter if you're you know
woman or man or any anybody deserves to
be pampered and enjoy their day at the
spa so highly recommend and then another
thing obviously I'm not alone in this
boat but music music is so important
music speaks to my soul in so many ways
music the right song can make me feel
better so musical chairs we're playing
some musical chairs and then the last
big race is the library maze reading a
good book you guys sometimes people
underestimate the power of reading a but
a good book and how good it feels and
being kind of absorbed by a story and
stuff like that's the library means I
put some hidden stuff in there I put
some books around and if you guys find
the books and return them to me
you'll win in a class ticket so yeah and
then the last one is basically the first
race in Reverse because you got to make
sure you're getting a good night's rest
got to make sure you're making that
sleep schedule nice and perfect and stay
energized staying healthy and I feel
like the combination of a lot of these
things during time forever really
stressed out and we're really worried
and we turn to bad habits to get through
those things maybe try one of these
instead so alright we said all that we
explained oh my god I love it okay let
me see
we already cool so we have four out of
the five ma'am you guys clean house I
love it I'm you know having those DIYs
there was cooler because everyone got a
chance to like get something new but
like seeing them all there all right
thanks we're waiting waiting on one more
[Music]
all right cool stuff
everyone's pockets should be empty
[Music]
all right so before I go any further let
me show you guys the map something's I'm
gonna get back no it's all good so we're
starting down here bottom Center I can't
really point to it very well for you
guys oh here we go
well bottom center where you see Town
Square a little bit to the right this is
where our first race is gonna be then to
the right of that is where our garden
greedy weeders race is gonna be north of
that one is where our spa scavenger hunt
is gonna be then to the left where you
see those little dots in the middle
that's where musical chairs will be and
then obviously the library means sticks
out like sore thumbs don't even need to
explain that but it leads all to the
left to our belt tree extravaganza
alright so let's see what our
contestants say alright let's do this oh
by the way you will see that the date is
not correct but that's because if some
southern hemisphere island and
[Music]
I got okay so it's snowing right now
actually on the southern hemisphere on
this current date so I went back a
little bit because I want the theme to
be more summery and all of that goes
well so here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I have to sign this first course like
I mentioned before rise in shine raise
everyone's picking a bed every track is
the same every track also nope okay
that's like going
[Music]
yeah they're also great they're also
great your guys are watching my you're
playing with your all sorry okay
all right ready
begin the start I'm excited
all right race you guys let's go we got
that timer we're gonna set the timer I
don't think we're gonna need five
minutes but we're gonna set it for five
minutes
ready egg so I set this up so we can see
where everyone's going Oh out of the
runway we do indeed have pitfalls needs
but it's all a part of the maze oh we
got one
okay our player here in the imperial van
looks like he's slightly ahead here all
right we've got some groups already
ahead
oh the prison the top cannot roll for
some reason alright they've turned on
the faucet that is a requirement let's
go see how our players they're making
their noise they're making indeed okay
we got someone getting their fruit noise
noise and there was a shovel there as
well so you know what that means I can
ask that eat the fruit and dig up a tree
this is the latter part okay what's
happening
thank you looking for me where are you
going
[Music]
all right so this is one of those races
where you kind of have to retrace your
steps and go back
Oh others like this might have been too
complicated this rousing the rover
tactics of this race were really gonna
come in strong okay there we go
begun all right let me see I feel like
there
[Music]
let me see you Oh No
Oh
[Music]
in my dad when I built this it did make
a lot Oh No Oh
I probably should have mentioned that yo
what's good Brandon Bivens and orion's
and everyone tuning in I'm just seeing
how our our pals are doing okay now okay
imma give them all an extra fruit yeah
cuz I noticed see I have the extra fruit
just in case this not rip because I was
worried that it might be too complicated
so I just kept me used on backup
Oh up
[Music]
just don't eat it before exactly as long
as you don't eat it before no don't
listen no okay he almost had it he
almost had it he needed that I've been
checking to see if anybody made it out
yet no one's made it out yet I think she
might've plasterer okay I might have to
go pick up
[Music]
she got through a big [ __ ] oh she left
her throw on her counter over there and
her shovel you're so close
you're so close I promise you all right
to shovel oh wait they still can't get
through it because I accidentally my bad
that was my boat I actually closed off
that one little area which was a little
accident
all right
[Music]
I feel like I think this is Mary saw
hair she figured out all of it except
for this last step right here
[Music]
the fish's eyes yeah wishes Donita fruit
to dig up I know I I went all in on this
yeah I miss Darla and I was like I
wonder my Island is so cool and flawless
buying this stuff right here look I
closed on her whole room on accident
that was my fault
but it's all good oh yeah you got
tricked
let's go all right now you just got it
yeah oh we found the fifth ball see she
didn't fall prey whoo guys keep in mind
everything that's buried could be
something all right
who she got it first and then he yes and
then he got a second
[Music]
right Thank You 10 I am having a great
time so far our first race has been
challenging for the players which is
good
aside from one error on my fur coat
which it probably wouldn't have been a
challenging a doula crash she definitely
would have had it much faster okay
someone's gonna be a winner here
regardless everyone's got their trees
[Music]
not quite oh I feel like we lost some
people can't
Pera let me give them when I thought I'd
drop them for him let me make sure we're
we're all best friends okay oh okay so
he needs four room hiding
because these trees are gonna be for
later
oops I fell trees so so far I see that
everyone left our gold nugget by bit I
hid one gold nugget right there but said
and then I put two hip I'll see you at
the bottom just kind of throw them off
the trail of the hidden gold but there
there's definitely gold okay so
[Music]
[Music]
where is our pal here okay
I think I fit in
[Music]
all right I'll hold on to this extra one
he's gonna need a ten fruit I don't know
where I got it from unless you ran over
here all right well that's first race
guys I'm actually proud of myself
because I worked really hard on this
first race and I wanted it to be a
challenge all right so I'm gonna make
sure I would like you a few another's
passport
okay cool
[Music]
all right so let me put my checkmark
over here for Marisol for winning the
first one round of applause very nice
all right
all right now we are on to the mixed
race this one is not as puzzly as the
first one was which is good because they
just get to run around and have fun and
do whatever they want all right when the
timer goes off when the timer
my typing is not good
[Music]
all right
everyone
alright looks like everyone is alright
let's do this setting the time we're
almost set the sign for 10 minutes yeah
we definitely don't need 10 minutes for
this one but yeah oh my gosh
honestly I planted all these leaves
right but if I it has like just walked
onto my Island everybody's everywhere
there's a people the best way to get it
all cleaned up but I remember when I
finally got my switch Animal Crossing
came out only 4 days before that thing
and you know you start your island and
you have to groom it you know yes it's
like all the weeds and everything look I
feel like that was one of the most
therapeutic and like peaceful parts of
the entire starting theme so
[Music]
oh my gosh it's actually so adorable and
by the way you guys if you're just
tuning in with us right now
don't forget today's stream is powered
by truth and that is why we are able to
give away all these bells and get an
even higher emerge from truth themselves
so thank you guys so much for tuning in
and with even more fun is that this is
one of two animal crossing things that
we're gonna do next week we're doing it
all again new games at bigger prizes if
you like what you see you know it's
gonna be a part of it try to get in on
the next one or in on these races but
good luck in the way I was worried you
mean good enough like I didn't plan
enough but
[Music]
[Music]
so now I think that's it I think
everyone's like you're on I'm not gonna
end it your life because they're still
too over there I'm looking at I'm not
gonna walk next time if I don't want
them to see then I see it all fit huh
it's like it's gonna find them them and
blending in Wow
[Music]
all right everyone the fountain
[Music]
all right let's have a lineup
[Music]
[Music]
66 68 72 6857 751 okay he was alright
let me just make sure I think this was
cheese yeah good job she's so close
everyone all right boom my cheese is on
the board
he's getting himself some IRL emerges
long all the swirls right here okay boom
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what happened sit again sitting in
[Music]
all right next up is the spot scavenger
hunt so
[Music]
I'm gonna stand here because I don't
want them to run to the musical chair so
don't see that RM you're gonna freak me
out there's no spiders on my chair okay
all right
[Music]
minute in the timer oops that's not what
I wanna know
[Music]
all right take care of the skin you know
all right okay
oh no I I'm like off by one winner big
I feel like this price complic I'm
complicating it okay
[Music]
any questions
[Music]
everything
lots of praise been lots of prize this
is like Twitter before the character
buff and lots of prizes where and sit in
a beach chair answer you win but there
but there's lots and he's really very
okay
let's do it
look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right I feel like I missed someone
there okay so I buried all the time
stuff and it's because I found out
recently you cannot bury deposit but ya
got Nick miles to get some laying about
there's gold nuggets I have some real
iron in there somewhere got some money
it's like she's got some money there but
gets the goal even though there's all of
these awesome prizes in here the goal is
to find a bathrobe and slippers the
facial mask optional but there's that
and there's a few summer patches and
then to run over to the beach and sit in
a chair fully dressed but you know I
wanted to make it's worth it is still
brush to define items and go because
there's a lot
Oh dad if you play I'll get it see
that's nice so not only with the amount
of people that are here I am in my swamp
look I've got to go chill Belle quit
what everyone's over there you know
working hard ah the relaxation I love it
Elsa I think Isaac cucumbers and
yeah
[Music]
very good so I'm pretty sure if
doubtless I'm just gonna I'm gonna make
sure I don't hit in session so that
would be yeah yeah all right good job my
yard for wedding but I respect that
everyone else is like there are some
good things to be one in here
oops I'm trying to class not talk yeah
okay because there would there was a lot
of good stuff I'm gonna make sure
everyone gets some stuff still have
musical chairs legs and then I'm gonna
have the library man I love this song I
like seeing everyone running around they
like pull out like money out of the
ground in their life I actually really
like how this area came out even though
it's just like
[Music]
relaxing over here I have the waterfall
and when you read next naturally
running water
yes they are threatening
five minutes took me like an hour to put
all this stuff into the ground they're
helping me
fill the whole night
[Music]
oh I wonder if Rockets are already
getting full I'm not oh thank you so
much
Oh Raman you should totally pick up this
game I would highly recommend super fun
especially when you get to do stuff like
this and there's something about
creating your own island that I really
enjoy I like like city building games up
to so this is like a cuter version of
that alright it looks like we are done
all right let's talk to the fault
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
my weights name is fine I think they
might have responded and I guess all
right good
thank you it was it exports and all
those these games to fit in with each
other so if you noticed in the first
race you dug up to trick you and now
when we got my musical chairs gonna be
using those trees as chairs all right
okay so let's go let's uh follow me
oh right this is the musical chairs area
I need to get some trees for our bolts
here if you did not grab their trees
from the first three okay so let me just
go ahead and get these trees this is
what I was doing - uh hey what let me
know alright fine
I have to go over here
No
[Music]
even I'm getting lost in my own man you
guys okay this little sneak peek at the
library manuals that we're going to next
but don't get any funny ideas nothing to
see here
yes I did go the most complicated route
that I did but is very fair but yeah if
you guys are just tuning in with us
right now and you didn't hear earlier we
are powered by truce today which is why
we are able to make all of these awesome
games happen and also hopefully spread
some awareness on some activities you
can do to combat stress and help you
avoid all those nasty habits um I'm
going to grab some good ol oranges so I
can go get nice and strong and dig up
these strings and then play musical
chairs that is the goal please Leo a
tree I think that's sky oh my gosh
spotting Thanks alright let's get back
to pulse okay
[Music]
so let's see here
so we will give to fruit grab grab grab
grab
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right wait was there more than one
person who didn't ountry thanks for
everything
[Music]
[Music]
all right this picture everyone is
equipped I guess I would consider these
trees like their intricacies into each
round
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
all right
see ya you know Chris the girls
understood all right let's see hey relax
with the ban hammers alright we've got
three out of five bolts ready to go
alright 4 out of 5 looks like we're
waiting on one more the music is written
and every hour the tune changes which I
didn't find out about for a long time
honey what okay let me go grab a jury
I need Adafruit you know I got a powerup
that vitamin C which is actually for
next week we are having another one of
these for next week you guys not forget
[Music]
set this up all nice light okay who is
ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know the drill
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right musical chairs
[Music]
drum solo I'm gonna make them run for it
I'm gonna make a run for a hot minute
okay all right round two
[Music]
you're out
[Music]
okay I actually really love his smooth
beat I'm like so off you would like the
ability in the background like alright
that was enough to rub blue wait one
lady
[Music]
[Music]
all right
rather you switch it up we're not on the
drugs Network Rhonda it's like a you sat
down really I gotta keep playing it make
sure no one gets the pre-emptive sis
they'll never know oh don't forgot a
coupon if I see this they accidentally
keeping it going to make sure no one
gets an unfair advantage
lucky son all right here we go here we
go three two
[Music]
hey I mean it practically oh my gosh
it's gonna be great
gotta keep them on their toes she's got
the skip run all going around and making
run that was super fun
[Music]
oh right
so we're putting a point on the board or
kernel and now game
[Music]
yeah yeah okay I like it this system I
know the tension right because he was
covered really close to the stump IV so
that if a wasp comes out of one of these
chains
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and just like that you gotta know we are
set up for round two you and I farmed a
little bit of wood because you know how
that goes all the hardwood and softwood
no regular wood whoo-hoo all right enjoy
Robin thanks for tuning in and enjoy
your I don't know why I made them plant
that tree into this but I'll go back to
the marimba oh god I accidently stopped
down to the short one it's like they
didn't notice
and the way game one is the first one
sky rocket
[Applause]
alright alright that was an accident I
accidentally open my pocket that's not
me like but I didn't want to just start
up the music again and then confuse them
all take the grandest the grandest of
pianos honestly I kind of like learning
a musical piece me I feel like ruining
an entrance with berries
[Music]
one to learn something like a ukulele
[Music]
penis ran straight over there and let's
go ahead and take away this that got
everyone still in their rooms even me I
didn't even pay attention to that
okay we're ready back on the grandest
[Music]
[Applause]
I like what I'm playing an instrument
and then my villagers come along and
they just like play it better than me
like get off this instrument you don't
know what you're doing
make work for this one
get those run and slippers on buddy
didn't this time oops
I doing that one on accident
[Music]
this did tell me that this doesn't
literally this alright final round
[Music]
[Music]
ok nice nice clockwise rotations what do
you mean we should stop it make a run
for like unfinished rate I mean I have
to keep in mind I have to press the
button industry but I mean people on
their toes around so it's there I'm
gonna look away and then stop I don't
want no favorites oh-oh the stalemate
then
alright that was really really like come
on scrappy
[Music]
[Music]
the tree me one
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay cool so he's gonna plant this tree
[Music]
all right and I'm just gonna dig this
one up again I realize by this fine
[Music]
oops I didn't wanna do that I was just
testing it to make sure you spit on it
all right let's begin going back to the
grand
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come on Mitch you can do it yeah I'm
taking up bright brown to my caps lock
on
whose turnips are going for a feast
money I've been come on oh [ __ ] I think
my afternoon prices were like 360 or
something
and if they are
maybe I can open up later on today
[Music]
oh he's funny he almost got his seat so
[Music]
whitey oops
testing it again just testing it again
you see the trick is I don't think you
can run into the seat and sit down I get
to stop walking and like look at it and
align yourself alright here we go back
to the drums
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right get excited last round of
musical chairs
Mitch swallows there is Mitch everyone
will have won a challenge a free one get
some true riches but I'm not a monkey -
this is not the lusion that was not a
sign of anything
all right I'll let me do the drums since
I could see the seats
[Music]
right come on Mitch I'm not commuting
but I'm rooting for you because whatever
you win it out my stop it oh my gosh all
right
[Music]
all right you guys
[Music]
I got a hype it up you know I gotta sell
it to them I gotta get
[Music]
and I'm going to start this timer I'm
gonna put it on the max amount of
minutes I think
and Alexa get up here let's see where
they go all right Erin you guys if you
are just now tuning into the stream well
we are powered by truth today and thanks
to them they've helped me created this
massive amazing a field day full of fun
and games and prizes all for our players
and contestants here and also giving me
some creative freedom I'm going to share
with you guys some things I used to cope
with stress whether it be listening to
music reading a book you know getting
myself a nice and pretty and ready for
the day just to give me that extra boost
of confidence then you know just
all-around little things that you might
not think of will definitely help combat
those stressful times
especially right now so thank you guys
so much for tuning and I hope you're
having a great time now let's go find
where everyone is I formulated it this
way so that I can hop around and
hopefully spy on everyone's progress
however I might stuck already so let's
just walk on down here cuz I'm missing
the action already heard a few people
run into the pit box someone's over so
fast
I heard them falling well Mitch found
the gold nuggets I had hiding over there
see Marysol's over here who she found
the Beltre very nice so she's making her
way she also found that Nichols ticket I
had hidden over there he is over here
he found it I put a big stack of gold
nuggets over there in that corner and I
made it really really difficult to get
through through the back awesome
so cool it's actually super fun because
I just like seeing how people go about
figuring out things I didn't see a how
hard it is for them to find stuff or in
general just get out of the trap and as
you know the map shows when you have
structures and everything so I tried to
fill in certain gaps with items so that
they wouldn't show up on the map and
make it extra complicated Brandon I put
you on the list for next week
anyone who is anyone sit in
participating in next week please either
send me your friend code on Twitter or
if you have if you're in our game spot
to spread I am also taking requests
there's but only five slots available
while forest slots available I just
filled up one slot from one of the
viewers in the top right now shout out
sopran and Hernandez who I see some
traffic over here now Murtagh made a
really far really fast so I think I need
to go check in on sushi me and the
country field already we know honestly I
wouldn't be surprised she was just
moving and grooving I don't even think I
see let's see is she you guys better
console she is a shake in those cheering
news oh they're close Kabaddi guys very
small taking it all away okay everyone's
caught up everyone has finally caught up
but there is a look at her oh oh or are
her pockets full hmm so that's the other
thing that was
she planted the bushes there her pockets
might be told to be honest pockets okay
she's just looking for places to plan
now her pocket full of bushes makes
sense cuz I put a bunch of bushes around
the maze also to make things a little
more difficult oh thank you Ray Mia I'm
sorry if I pronounced that wrong alright
it looks like all of our faults alright
have surpassed the maze took them about
five and a half minutes to get through
this man hopefully they got all the good
stuff and now they're here this is
honestly part I wanted to see the most
because it took me so long to farm all
over a million dollars in Belcher you
and I just wanted to see that's why I
put a second player over here I can
stand upon my mountain and watch them
shake all the money their pockets are
full see this is what I wanted though I
wanted to put enough prizes for everyone
to get cool stuff and also get a lot of
money but hopefully not so much space
that one person would make it to the end
of the maze and then be you know get
everything and no one else had anything
so I do feel like this win really really
well super fun they're going slowly
through the belamis because they're
pocketable which is actually great all
right let me let them out because we
still have our final race but actually
we we are that time and the final
research is a reverse of the first race
everyone did win a challenge which was
the main goal here there's still some
few trees left it's even so hard to even
just walk through this because there's
just so many trees and there's probably
gonna be some some bells hidden under
this you guys saw here at first we had
so much money in so many prizes to give
away that the pockets simply could not
handle the power the power that was
brought to us by truth if you're just
now tuning in with us yes you guys we
are packed I should say that is what
made all of this happen and I put so
much fun and I'm very excited that we're
gonna do it again next week so if you're
interested like I said before we're
taking five more entrants we already
have one slot claimed by someone in the
chat right now please please please DM
me on Twitter if you would like to be a
part of the next stream and of course
while everyone's still going through
this spell we have so much money laying
around that we can't even get it all I
love it I love it's madness it's great
it's fanciful they're eating the fruit a
guy need pockets peas but yeah you guys
so for next time we have some games plan
yes because obviously played games today
but these games are gonna be different
the prices are gonna be bigger and
better I'm gonna try to figure out
something for pockets for the next one
but oh my gosh this was so much fun here
are at the here's the Creator ID for all
of the truth emerged she does refer
those to be interested in joining us
next time because next time we're come a
fashion show that's right the fashion
show we are going to have
for themes designated is gonna be an
orange theme as in the color an orange
theme as in the fruit an Exercise theme
and a beach theme and then players
choice outfits that's gonna be a part of
our oh I was trying to hype up the next
stream while everyone was hanging out
thank you so much her pockets were
definitely full she won a lot everyone
won a challenge today which means
everyone's walking away with some merch
which is just super awesome so guys I'm
definitely gonna be hitting you up for
your information to get you those things
and next stream we're gonna have all
that merchant stuff too so I'm not gonna
shut things off just yet because maybe
she wanted into your pockets and coming
back not sure we're definitely gonna be
wrapping up the stream here in a few
minutes but I have to gush about the
next stream because it's going to be so
fun so while we go through that yes
please download one of these items
because it will be needed for one of the
outfits next week if you are a
contestant we are gonna have the rise
and shine race version two we're gonna
have the tree transport challenge we're
gonna have our Muscle Beach Fashion Show
and then we're gonna have the boosted
Beltre race everything is going to be
different but this time it's all themed
about boosting your immunity which might
make more sense now that you've heard
some of the challenges for next week and
a lot of them involve eating oranges
moving trees getting strong staying
healthy
and he also lived in more detail about
the theme of all of those races next
time like I did with today's stream and
like I said earlier you guys try some of
these out might help you with your
stress a lot of these things I think
you've probably done a lot before in the
past and maybe you you know got out of
touch with it over time for me reading
is one of those things I used to read so
much I kind of ran out of time to read
as much as I used to I started listening
to audiobooks a lot which was kind of
good and kind of back of us there is
something nice about flipping a page and
feeling the paper and closing the book
when you're done with it but audiobooks
are really cool too so there's a lot of
ways you guys can combat your stress
during these signs n you know every day
in life and hopefully you can turn to
some news instead of those nasty habits
once again we were powered by truth
today and we are running it back next
week so hopefully you guys will tune
back in and see the madness we gave away
millions of Belle's I gave away almost
100 gold nuggets almost 50 duck miles
tickets it was a lot and next week we're
doing it all again and more so thank you
guys so so much for tuning in and by the
time we're powered by truth thank you so
much stay safe
you